m
le premier marché pays du nouveau
conseil départemental s'est déroulée au
jardin de l'état en marché un peu
particulier puisqu'il a eu lieu la
veille de la fête des mères l'accent a
été mis sur les fleurs mais également
sur les produits de saison
une trentaine de producteurs étaient
présents certains venus de loin tous
ravis d'exploser au jardin de l'état
c'est l'idéal parce qu'il ya de la place
pour stationner il ya plein de monde les
gens il vient en même temps il profite
du temps ils profitent de du comment
dire du site et en même temps il faudra
marcher on nous société une fois de
venir ici et coûter jusqu'à présent ce
disons ça va bien je dirais
non je suis content
en tout cas je dis bien 6e
c'est général si c'est possible de faire
une fois dans le mois
c'est bien et en eau agriculture et sur
le producteur c'est une fois dans le
mois pour nous c'est mieux quoi parce
que je trouve que sur ceux d'un jardin
d'état c'est plus y a plus place et puis
même pour le poids gare et les visiteurs
présents ont pu apprécier les jus de
fruits frais les goyaviers le palmiste
ou encore les confitures nombreux
étaient ceux à prendre d'assaut les
stands de fleurs un air de fête régnait
au jardin et à à l'occasion de la fête
des mères mais je tout c'est une
excellente idée
premièrement aujourd'hui on a de la
chance je suis beau c'est magnifique
il ya du soleil a pas de plus il n'y a
pas de vent pas beaucoup et je trouve
que c'est vraiment une très bonne idée
une avoir organisé ce pour plusieurs
raisons d'ailleurs c'est l'occasion de
se retrouver
c'est l'occasion de se revoir
il ya un aspect des petits convivialité
abbas espère pascal à la veille de la
fête de nerfs on trouve tout sur place
et il peut faire un joli cadeau pour les
mamans balle effleure les frileux pays
c'est très bel espace sabine dijoux
passionnés de cuisine à profiter de ce
marché pour dédicacer son livre pour
l'occasion à la proposer au public une
dégustation de riz chauffé brochettes de
poulet et gâteaux maison aujourd'hui
avec le conseil général
on a mis en place une dégustation avec
le pot les produits des producteurs qui
sont sur le site
sachant que c'est la fête des mères
demain partage effectivement tout
l'amour de la cuisine que j'ai avec les
mamans et donc on a mis en promotion mon
livre aujourd'hui avec la dédicace à
travers un événement comme le marché
pays le conseil départemental soit
répondre aux attentes du public et des
producteurs et mettre en avant les
produits locaux